[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
why are you doing this
why are you fighting this needless war
this war of conquest that will topple so
many lives
he sent his forces his missiles in the
middle of the night
these are the troops hundreds of
thousands of them that had been camped
out on the border for months
troops that putin had insisted were
there for a routine military exercise
and that the u.s and uk intel swore were
actually preparing to invade
many around the world including in
ukraine thought that this was just the
west being dramatic
stoking the tensions
but the intel was exactly right
most of those troops crossed the border
last week and are now inside the country
russian military vehicles including
tanks entering ukraine the invasion the
attack that russia promised would never
happen
has now started the country is being
attacked from all directions
hours after this invasion started in the
middle of the night on thursday morning
ukraine's president zielinski appeared
on tv not just to talk to his people
but to speak directly to russians
themselves
we share a border of over 2 000
kilometers and along this border your
troops are stationed almost 200 000
soldiers
your leaders just approved them to make
a step towards us into the territory of
another country
this step is likely the beginning of a
massive war on the european continent
russia again warned its nuclear forces
were on high alert several cities were
hit in residential areas resulting in
dozens of civilian deaths
this is a war unlike any war the world
has ever seen it looks like a war from
like 1830 but it's happening in 2022
putin's army is much stronger than
ukraine's at least in terms of numbers
if he really wants to he probably is
going to be able to take over the
country's major population centers and
oust the ukrainian government the u.s
and nato can't send troops for fear of
starting a clash between two nuclear
nations something we simply do not do
it's a red line that no one crosses
i want to tell you exactly why vladimir
putin and his army are here the story
behind this invasion is the story of
this one man's worldview but it's also a
story of a bet that he took a bet that
ukrainians would give up lay down their
arms and see the world the way he does
but if there's anything i have learned
in the past week it's that even if putin
conquers a big portion of this country
something he has the military hardware
to do even if he does that he still
won't win this war
in fact i'm here to argue
that he's already lost there are big
explosions taking place in kiev right
now people here are going to be waking
up to a very different country than the
one they went to sleep
we are getting this non-stop reports of
attacks and russian strikes from all
across the country
[Music]
vladimir putin has already lost this war
and to understand what i'm talking about
you have to look at two things number
one what putin said right before the
invasion
and number two what actually happened
once he invaded
i want to show you both
[Music]
so a few days before the invasion putin
gets on tv and addresses the nation
[Music]
it's this unsurprising hour-long history
lecture where putin lays out his grand
intricate argument
as to why ukraine in fact isn't a real
country
[Music]
instead ukraine was created by the
authors of the russian communist
revolution 100 years ago and now ukraine
this invented country that's just an
extension of russia itself has been
hijacked by the u.s and europe who have
installed neo-nazi thugs to run the show
seriously he said all of this
you can go watch the hour-long lecture
if you want according to his story the
west did this to eventually force
ukraine into their military alliance
called nato which they will use to
defeat russia just like and seriously he
says this just like hitler did 80 years
ago but this time putin will make sure
that russia is ready for the invasion
oh gosh there is a lot to unpack here
the neo-nazi thug thing i will get to
that in a second but the message was
clear putin was basically like ukraine
if you're gonna disavow communist russia
and all of the things that it gave to
you you don't deserve the land that you
got from communist russia and in fact
all of this land still belongs to russia
and we're going to take it back
[Music]
but this warped historical framing of
who rightfully owns this land isn't
quite enough to justify an invasion
maybe in like 1860 or something but not
today so putin needs to really emphasize
the villains in his story so he makes a
big part of his story this idea that
ukraine this fake country
is being run by american-backed
anti-russian neo-nazis who are holding
the ukrainian people hostages
okay okay
it's easy to poke fun at like the
delusion of vladimir putin but let's
talk about the facts here and what putin
is actually basing this off of because
it really matters for understanding why
he went in and why he's gonna lose first
let's just clear up the fact that
ukraine wasn't invented by russia kiev
the capital of ukraine was a thriving
city long before moscow was even on the
map ukraine has a very old culture but
what putin has done is twisted modern
history to make a claim that ukraine
actually isn't a legitimate country and
he does this because it's a very key
part of his story one that supports the
second major argument which is that
ukraine is run by neo-nazis who want to
exterminate the russian-speaking
population so let's get the facts here
within ukraine there is indeed a faction
of far-right neo-nazis who have a
political party and a militia force and
this militia force has actually joined
the ukrainian army in the past eight
years to fight russia back from annexing
any more territory in the east of the
country you may have remembered that
russia took over a big part of ukraine
called crimea eight years ago
ukrainian forces have set up a perimeter
but it's clear that we are completely
surrounded by russian forces yeah these
neo-nazi fighters sort of nationalist
guys came up as a resistance to that and
yeah putin's got one thing right these
are not good people these are literal
neo-nazi white supremacist soldiers that
commit all sorts of atrocities and train
children in their ideology and fighting
tactics
[Music]
so yeah putin i get it these are bad
people neo-nazis we don't like them but
putin is claiming that these are the
people running the country running
ukraine when in fact if you look at the
data from the 2019 election in ukraine
you'll see that the country's
ultra-nationalist far-right coalition
gained barely over two percent of the
vote and zero seats in the parliament
they are a small group of extremely
fringe far right fighters that putin has
latched on to oh and there's a more
obvious bit of data here which is that
the ukrainian president is jewish and
has family who died in the holocaust
ukraine is not run by neo-nazis listen
to balance my view on this because i'm
in the west and i'm getting all western
media i have actually been watching
russian state tv to like see what the
narrative is on their side and i can
tell you that they actually believe that
the country is run by nazis it is
reminiscent of the practices and methods
of nazi germany and we're seeing a full
revival of nazism and fascism in ukraine
i've tried to dig into this to try to
understand like is there more like meat
on the bone here no there's not a fringe
group of militiamen in the far east are
what putin is basing this off of over
here in reality land ukraine is a nation
of 44 million people with its own
culture that is thousands of years old
it is a country where fewer and fewer
people like russia in fact it's a
country that ousted the pro-russian
leader in 2014
[Music]
the people don't want russia and putin
anymore they've moved on but all of
these facts are explained away very
conveniently by putin's bigger
conspiracy which is that it's actually
outside forces that are pulling the
strings and that the people of ukraine
have been brainwashed by the west and
yet there is one thing that putin is
absolutely right about
[Music]
these two countries are deeply connected
through culture and language and history
and exchange a war against ukrainians
would not sit well with the russian
people and this explains why putin needs
to frame the war in a very certain way
not an invasion to take over a sovereign
nation of russia's brothers and sisters
but rather a rescue effort to save the
ukrainian people from these aggressive
villains who are really controlling the
country
okay i'm about to jump into the maps and
look at how the war is actually playing
out and help us understand it but i
really really want us to keep in mind
putin's story because it really will
make everything click so let's just go
over it really quickly putin's story is
really four things number one ukraine
really belongs to russia number two it
has been hijacked by the us and europe
i.e the west number three the west is
controlling ukraine with its neo-nazi
puppets also that the west military
alliance called nato can use ukraine as
a bridge to get to russia who they want
to defeat and all of this leads to putin
must invade to free ukrainians and
protect russia from the west that is it
that is the justification that vladimir
putin has been building
minutes after this second address last
week where he laid out all of his
justifications in the middle of the
night the rockets start flying
and the tanks start rolling
[Music]
and this is how it started what is
becoming the most consequential war in
europe since world war ii a pretend
rescue effort framed as an operation to
denotify the country russia comes in
from all sides quickly taking over
mostly rural areas but slowly moving
towards the major cities the country is
being attacked from all directions some
of those russian troops are heading here
to the capital in addition to tanks and
troops taking over land russia also
starts firing missiles that hit targets
all throughout the country this has come
out of nowhere who resist oh
i tell you what i just heard a big bang
right here
the invasion the attack that russia
promised would never happen
has now started
people who live in kiev are sleeping in
underground subway stations it's the
only place they feel safe ukrainians
fled to basements to bomb shelters some
people are adjusting to this new reality
of living in a country now a war
hundreds of thousands fled to the
borders west of the country looking for
safety others are taking trains to the
west to get out of the country they are
fleeing into neighboring countries like
moldova romania and poland at the city's
central train station a frantic dash as
all of these people tried
but wait remember putin's story
according to this story after this
initial invasion ukrainians were going
to wake up from their slumber and
welcome him with open arms the neo-nazi
president was gonna flee and ukraine
would be returned to russia putin
becoming the savior of the russian
motherland but that is exactly what
didn't happen outgunned and outnumbered
ukrainian soldiers and civilians alike
are mounting a stiff resistance i used
to teach maths and physics but two days
ago the russian army took control of my
town so i signed up to fight every day
ukrainians are taking to the streets to
fight for their homeland
those russian shits come here she says
we are ready to greet them we are ready
to fight
and like fights like hell this is my
city this is my land i have to protect
it you do not feel they're going to
succeed in taking out your
administration and your government no
way
as they will never take
the response of ukrainians both military
and civilian is where putin's story
starts to crumble the entire world is
witnessing the determined and brave
resistance
by the ukrainian army and population i
have never seen ukraine said united and
as for the president of ukraine the
alleged neo-nazi drug addict thug puppet
of the west well the u.s actually
offered to airlift him out of the
country for his own safety instead of
taking the offer his response was quote
the fight is here i need ammunition not
a ride which by the way that quote has
been turned into a t-shirt that you can
buy on amazon ukrainians are fighting
for love of country russians are
fighting out of a fear of a dictator in
the event of russia opting for
escalation ukraine will defend itself he
then sent a video around
to the country of him in central kiev
making it known that he is staying he is
fighting so despite being totally
outmatched militarily ukrainians are
fighting back showing that the outcome
of a war is as much determined by the
courage and patriotism of the population
as it is by the number of missiles and
troops that you have
[Music]
i've been talking to people inside
ukraine and seeing this devotion
firsthand how is morale right now among
you and among the people you're talking
to honestly extremely exciting
ukrainians aren't letting this conquest
happen and in doing so they are turning
putin's argument his story on its head
and foiling what appears to be his
initial strategy for wrangling ukraine
back into his sphere of influence one
ukrainian i talked to said that there's
a waiting list for the ukrainian army
our original defense won't accept any
more people because it's packed the
queues are growing you cannot you even
get in right now men volunteering to
fight molotov cocktails for those who
want to fight but don't have a gun it's
a tweet from the ukrainian defense
ministry to prepare molotov cocktails to
throw at the occupiers well i'm here in
order to protect my family my country
there is
an incredible sense of unity here the
morale is very high okay this sounds all
positive and it is but this is still war
and putin can still conquer a lot of
land he can take over major cities
install a puppet government and be the
new ruler of ukraine he has the military
to do it and he seems to have the
tolerance for bloodshed he seems to
believe in his fantasy story so much
that he's gonna keep up this crusade but
i'm here to tell you that putin has
already lost this war
i mean let's play this out so i can show
you what i mean let's say putin keeps
going he keeps sending troops in and
missiles despite all of this resistance
he could eventually take over the major
population centers including the capital
kiev all of this with the same goal that
he's had the whole time which is getting
the ukrainians to give up and realize
that russia is actually the country they
want to align with he's also kind of
hoping that maybe the ukrainian military
will come to their senses and take over
the government and negotiate with putin
but let's say they never do they
probably won't instead they keep doing
what they've been doing for the last
week resisting defending condemning and
broadcasting all of it to the world on
the internet so putin has no choice but
to drive the government out and install
a pro-russian regime in order to do this
he's going to need a massive military
presence to keep control of these cities
and their people it's now costing him
tens of billions of dollars and
crippling his economy which by the way
is only like the size of texas i mean
one of the biggest knocks on putin's
plan is the sheer size of ukraine let's
zoom out and realize that ukraine is
huge it's the biggest country in europe
if you don't count russia the giant
country that extends into asia occupying
this entire land mass would be basically
impossible for russia so you have a map
that maybe looks something like this
which gives plenty of space for
ukrainians to gather and mount their
resistance
giving russia hell for an indefinite
period of time meanwhile back home in
russia they've now seen the imagery from
the ground they now see that putin's
story justifying this invasion is total
bs there's no nazis there's no
brainwashing of the people instead in
this scenario russians are thinking of
deaths of our ukrainian brothers and
sisters while also destroying the
russian economy almost every russian has
someone from ukraine either a friend or
a relative or a colleague this is a war
between brother nations protesters in
the streets demonstrating against
vladimir putin's invasion of
ukraine on top of all of that the rich
russian business guys who keep putin in
power the oligarchs they aren't happy
because the entire world has cut russia
off russian billionaires moving their
yachts scrambling their jets and
shifting their assets to prepare for a
possible crackdown they can't access
their financial reserves their ability
to move money is made much more
difficult people aren't letting their
trade vessels into ports new efforts by
u.s law enforcement to make russian
oligarchs feel the pain of putin's war i
mean this is effectively what sanctions
do so the oligarchs are now like dude
putin wtf and they put pressure on him
to stop this madness but even still
putin has enough power that he could
still dig in his heels and keep trying
to get ukrainians to come under his rule
but by this point ukrainians are done
with putin they see his true colors
anyone who was on the fence before has
now witnessed civilians being killed in
putin's war of choice they won't come on
his side now the upshot here is that
there's not really a scenario where
putin keeps going and gets what he wants
and that's because the story that he
based this invasion off of is proving to
be totally wrong all of these
assumptions that he predicated his war
on turned out to be the delusions of a
pseudo-history buff stuck in the logic
of the cold war not the realities on the
ground today at another point to the
against putin camp meanwhile putin's war
has united the west and nato like never
before nato has a new sense of purpose a
new thing to rally around something
they've been looking for since the end
of the cold war and ukraine who is
currently getting tons of support and
weapons and money and aid and refugee
support from nato countries is now way
more likely to sympathize with the west
because now they've seen the realities
of what putin has to offer which is
falsehoods and unprovoked conflict all
in the name of some ill-defined vision
of former imperial glory
nope
it's my city it's my hometown it's my
homeland it's my country and i'm not the
one who should live the russians are the
ones who should live russia is a great
nation full of beautiful culture
geography history and people the vast
majority of those people don't want
imperial style expansion and war they
want to live their lives to prosper to
connect and yet
the warped delusional world view
of one greedy man has cut off their
ability to do that how is that possible
the russian people have no say in the
behavior of their government under the
putin dictatorship these incredibly
brave people often young people in
russia who are out on the streets
protesting against what their president
is doing this is not the war by the
people of russia it says yet another
military adventure by the unaccountable
unelected increasingly deranged dictator
in a kremlin by the name of vladimir
this situation is developing and
certainly will take paths that no one
can predict by the time you're watching
this i'm sure some key development has
happened that i haven't covered here but
i feel pretty certain when i say that
putin really doesn't have a path to the
victory that he set out to achieve last
week when he sent people and weapons
across his border to attack his
neighbors ukrainians with their bold
courage have proved him wrong i know
that sounds very poetic and maybe even
cliche but in this case it's true if
someone told me a week ago i would own
an assault rifle i would not believe so
now the world will stand by and support
as they continue to wage this battle for
the future of their land land that
belongs to them not to a russian
dictator
[Music]
for everyone to know it's our land it's
our home we will defend it 13 ukrainian
border guards defiantly telling and
invading russian warship to go f
yourself when asked to surrender and we
will win
russian ship go [ __ ] yourself
before you go i want to tell you about
two things that
are important number one i want to give
money to the relief effort in ukraine
there's a lot of need right now i'm
running a fundraiser where i'm going to
match donations up to ten thousand
dollars information in the description
number two i need to thank today's
sponsor who made this video possible
thank you nordvpn for supporting this
video a vpn is a useful tool that allows
you to connect to the internet but
through a different country it also
allows you to surf the internet without
being tracked and to do so more securely
i use a vpn when i travel and i'm in a
different country and i need to log into
my gmail and so i route my connection
through
the united states so that the internet
doesn't think i'm someone else trying to
get into my email it's just super
convenient to use a vpn when you're in a
different country i also use a vpn to
log on to like netflix or any other
streaming service and get access to way
more content because you can log in via
other countries and now you have all of
the content that is available in those
countries in addition to what's
available in your country it's just
awesome i've watched so many things this
way oh and they just added a new feature
that is called threat protection which
blocks trackers it blocks malicious and
intrusive ads it blocks harmful websites
and malware a vpn is just like shield
for surfing the internet but also like a
portal for getting to different versions
of the internet it's just like such a
useful tool i don't know oh and you
don't have to be like a tech person to
use this it's super easy it's like one
click you can even make it automatic it
connects it doesn't slow your internet
down it's just a quick easy tool that
sort of just runs in the background
luckily it's very cheap and they're
offering viewers of this channel an
exclusive discount at my link
nordvpn.com johnny harris if you click
that link it helps support this channel
it also gets you a great deal on a vpn
which is actually like not very
expensive to begin with my favorite part
about the whole thing is that if you
don't like it or you realize you don't
need it or whatever you have 30 days to
get all of your money back i'm a big fan
of nordvpn not only because they make a
good product but because they support my
channel like i focus on a lot of thorny
difficult topics and nord is like way
down with that and they are a supporter
of this journalism so thank you nordvpn
for supporting this channel thank you
all for watching this is an unfolding
situation in ukraine
it's but again by the time you're
watching this it's probably in such a
different place than it was but doing my
best to keep up with it and i hope this
video was helpful to all of you have a
good day
[Applause]
you